Lot to talk about.
Of course we're still in the
midst of a global pandemic.
Which is why we're here in this theater.
And you may have seen a
lot of the critical data
being charted and graphed by the CDC.
Now I mentioned this recently,
some of these graphs,
it's so confusing.
We're getting bombarded
with graphs all the time.
You don't know what they
mean and adding to that,
some of the graphs people are putting out
just seem a little unnecessary.
For example, check this one out.
There's been a 60% increase
in people eating morning lasagna.
Is that something we need to know?
I know it's a good idea.
True.
Check this out, a 550%
increase in women named Karen
going by their middle name.
Yeah.
There's a seven thousand percent increase
in Americans googling
Canadian citizenship.
There's an 80% increase
in rooting for the
sharks during shark week.
(laughter)
We're all sick of humans right now.
Yeah, come on.
Let the sharks have one.
(laughs)
Just one shark week,
let the sharks win.
You're right.
Let's hope they win this week.
Hey, 75% increase in board
game related stabbings.
I can understand that.
[Andy] Yeah.
A 600% increase in
adults overheard yelling,
"Hope your haircut was worth it, dad!"
That was kind of grime one.
Yeah, yeah.
Unless dad cut his own hair.
Hey, this one just says data.
Don't know what to do with that one.
Hey, check this out.
A steady increase in COVID infections
per item of Tommy Bahama clothing owned.
That one will get cut.
(laughter)
Here we see the answer to the question,
"Why are we having cereal
for dinner, mommy?"
20% because mommy's on a Zoom,
80% because mommy had gin for breakfast.
Mommy's an alcoholic,
that's the joke there.
Is that one to end on?
Maybe not, but we're
in an abandoned theater
and we're losing our minds.
(laughs) Don't say abandoned.
The owner's right here.
It's not abandoned.
It's abandoned.
Jesus, he doesn't own
anything but that Cadillac
and it's probably rented.
"Have a Genesis at nine in
the morning," says Flanny.